your life chairman thank you
thank you uh good evening everybody and
welcome to this extraordinary council
meeting today
thursday the 29th of april my name is
councillor mark hurd and i'm the
chairman of orton district council
this meeting is held under regulations
which came into effect
on the 4th of april 2020 in response to
the covid situation
and there's just a few housekeeping
issues to run through
first of all please could ask everybody
present in this meeting to ensure that
your microphone remains muted when not
addressing the council
this will reduce background noises and
avoid
any unintentional disturbances this
meeting is being hosted remotely
streamed live and recorded and by being
present in the meeting
you are giving consent to being recorded
members and officers during each item
please use the hands up function of the
meeting
to indicate if you wish to speak i will
then invite you at the appropriate time
members are reminded that apart from
indicating points of order
or that you have to leave the meeting
the chat function
should not be used for questions or any
other purpose
when speaking and referring to the
agenda papers
please ensure you reference the page or
paragraph number
and keep your contributions as clear and
concise as possible
when invited to speak please ensure you
turn on your microphone
now if i may ask officers taking part in
the meeting to
introduce themselves starting with mr
dodson
good evening members paul dodson
director of strategy performance and
governance
good evening thank you mr holmes
good evening members richard holmes
director of service delivery
good evening mr leslie
good evening chris leslie director of
resources
thank you mr quelch simon quelch
one of the legal advisers here at the
council
thank you good evening mr lee
chairman he's not here tonight okay
thank you very much
miss hughes
good evening cheryl hughes programs
performance and governance manager
thank you very much and miss bird uh
good evening chairman leaving member
torah bird committee clark for the
meeting thank you
thank you tara i can ask are there any
other officers present please if they
could identify themselves
no okay thank you very much tara can you
please now carry out a roll call of
members
to confirm who is in attendance thank
you
thank you chairman members if you could
just indicate your attendance when i
call your name please
starting with councillor bassinger
president thank you tara thank you
councilman
president casa bryan bill
castle of
thank you councillor boyce yeah
thank you councilman um hi everyone uh
good evening officers and members um i'm
president tara thank you miss byrd thank
you
thank you very much casa darren
president
thank you thank you councillor edwards
present
thank you council mrs fleming present
tara thank you
thank you councillor fleeker president
miss bird
yes good evening i'm present thank you
councillor hell
present
present thank you councillor jarvis
erin tara chairman members thank you
councillor keys good evening thomas
chairman members good opening present
thank you good evening councillor
very good evening everybody i'm present
castle maze
present tara good evening thank you
councillor morley
good evening present you councillor
morris
good evening and welcome
councillor mum yes good evening everyone
presents
uh tara thank you council shawnee
uh good evening everyone present tara
thanks
councillor good evening tara present
good evening to our good evening chair
good evening everyone
thank you stamp and present tara
tara did you call out cancer dueck did i
miss cancer duik
no we've got apologies from councillor
juric oh okay thank you tara
present thank you council stilts
good evening present council swain
yes good evening peasant tara thank you
mrs thompson good evening miss berg
yes president and i have just put in the
chat counselor white is having trouble
accessing the meeting um
i'm not sure if anyone out there can
help her uh
i think she might i think she might be
in but i'm not sure if she can speak
because i think i'm not sure about that
but i think she might be
in the meeting from what i've picked oh
okay
right sorry and as you were i'll shut up
so you can carry on with the roll call
apologies miss bird and everyone thank
you
and council miss white uh
thank you maddie um i did manage to get
in but i have said my broadband's very
ropey so i won't
leave the video on and i do apologize
looking a bit scruffy but i've literally
just walked in the door but because the
traffic was bad
but welcome everybody and i'm present
thank you
council council white you are almost
scruffy enough to be an independent now
um tara could you just confirm
councillor beal
i think uh may have logged on could you
just check that
not
are you there council bill yes i can see
him chairman he is present
thank you for that thank you very much
thank you
we'll move on now to uh agenda item two
um can i have any apologies for absence
please tara
uh yes chairman apologies have been
received from councillor juric thank you
very much
thank you very much agenda item number
three
declaration of interest to disclose the
existence and nature of any disclosable
pecuniary interests
other pecuniary interests or
non-pecuniary interests
relating to items of business on the
agenda having regard to paragraphs
six to eight inclusive of the code of
conduct for members
members are reminded that they're also
required to disclose any such interests
as soon as they become aware should the
need arise
throughout the meeting if any member has
an interest to declare
please use the hands up function now to
indicate
and i will invite you to speak
tara has uh any of any members
asked to speak i can see one hand but i
can't see whose it is
uh councillor durham has requested to
speak
and a councillor bell has indicated that
she uh has a declaration
uh in relation to agenda item six
but she's unable to um believe she's
unable to turn her camera on
and i've also got uh councillor missy's
channel as well
thank you i'll take councillor durham
first please
thank you chairman chairman of interest
as a member of essex county council
uh and any items on the agenda
that pertain to that organization thank
you
thank you very much um i have had um
a message from councillor bell declaring
an interest
in agenda item number six and i think
that she will be
uh leaving the meeting at that time um
councillor channel uh thank you chairman
um i declare non-pecuniary interest um
and that i'm also a member of essex
county council um chairman and therefore
um i can't go into any greater detail on
that because it relates more to
the private and confidential item thing
thank you very much um tara had uh i
can't see anybody anybody else indicated
they wish
to speak and no chairman that's
everybody i believe thank you very much
thank you councillor durham and jenna
you've still got your hands up well
thank you very much uh agenda item
four is about future committee option
reviews
and we move to this agenda item
which is found on pages 3 to 14. that in
a moment
i'll call on the leader to present this
item
so members a reminder if you wish to
speak on this item please make this
known by using the hands up function
and then i will come to you in turn
please keep your points clear and
succinct thank you leader please
introduce the report
okay thank you chair thank you members
uh well we all hopefully received a copy
of the high court challenge yesterday
that
uh um was decided uh and obviously that
we have to go
to face-to-face meetings from the 7th
of may um i'll read the recommendations
obviously little one on the
recommendations on the report members is
no longer
necessary because it's not happened so
i'm going to go to uh
little two but a b and c in order and
then i'm going to ask
mr dudson to present and give the
information for the report
and then members will be able to debate
it so let's
a is that members move the physical
statutory annual meeting to a start time
of 11
a.m to allow for this to take place
and an outside venue with the wider
staff on site to support
b members is that members review the
future
meetings option in section 3.10.6
below and identify a preferred option
having regard to the risk
set out at appendix a and accept any
costs
and that will be a budget pressure for
the year
and see that members adopt the guidance
set out in section 3.10.7 below
and additional guidance that emerges
from risk assessments to support
more secure physical meetings where they
do take
place now i'm sure that some members
would like
some amendments going forward but i'm
going to ask mr dodson
to present the report as comprehensively
as possible for members
thank you mr dodson just before we do
that could i just have a seconder for
that please
seconder for that motion
um
just got in there first thank you very
much carry on mr dodson
thank you chairman and good evening
members
uh this report seeks to update members
and to present options for
future committee meetings and as the
leaders
just outlined unfortunately the the high
court dismissed the application
i had so llg and hertfordshire county
council in relation to virtual meeting
provision
concluding that the original legislation
doesn't allow for remote meetings
and again as the leader said this means
recommendation i in the report no longer
stands
so um the review of options needs to be
for those um
regarding um undertaking remote meetings
offices are hard at work operationally
planning a covered secure statutory
annual council meeting for the 20th of
may
there's a statutory requirement for the
council to hold the annual meeting by
the end of may
and it will need to take place
physically after the legislation expires
as it needs to include the members who
will be elected to the two vacant seats
on council
following the election on the 6th of may
as the planning work for this meeting
continues um
we'll be able to issue further
information about how the meeting
will run um i set out in the
recommendations we're seeking to move
the start time of the meeting to 11 a.m
and this is to allow for wider staff
support with the new setup
and public streaming and also to allow
for off-site venue availability
um this meeting needs to be off-site as
the council chamber isn't large enough
to accommodate a socially distanced
meeting of full council
following the annual meeting there are
various options in terms of how we make
decisions going forward
they're set out in section 3.10.6 of the
report
and these are ranked by score which has
been calculated based on achievability
and impact
and members are asked to review these
and to define the preferred option
for all physical meetings there's an
element of both risk and cost
and these are highlighted in the paper
and appendix a to the report
so that members can consider the
implications of the options presented
as part of developing these future
meeting options
we have an officer working group
including legal lead specialist place
lease specialist community and ict and
committee's colleagues that are fed into
and reviewed the emerging information
the guidance set out at 3.10.7 for
member review and adoption
is based on standard risk assessment
that we've also been using for the
elections
and interpretation of the guidance for
covid safe use of council buildings
linked in the report under background
papers
we know this is a challenging decision
for members to make and as officers
we've been disappointed that the remote
meeting legislation expired
public engagement with our remote
meetings has been much higher
than for previous face-to-face meetings
ahead of that legislation being in place
and we've invested a lot of work to
develop efficient digital meetings
additionally there are risks associated
with a move back to physical meetings
but these are minimized as you'll see
through the risk assessments
however we invite members to review the
information set out to identify a
preferred approach for future meetings
with a further review to take place
again as restrictions are lifted
thank you chairman thank you very much
so this has been seconded by council of
maids so i'll now invite
members to make any comments
um i can see that councillor stilts
has asked uh to speak and
counselor morris so i'll start with
councillor stills
thank you mr chairman i do object to
recommendation um little too
i that the start time is at 11 a.m
because
any uh council councillor
who works is not going to be able to
attend that meeting
and i think that stops us doing what is
our statutory right and attending a
council meeting
okay thank you for that uh counselor
maurice
thank you mr chairman um if you don't
mind i'd like to start with a little bit
of a preamble
um i've looked at this report and um
i think it's blatantly terrible um
recently we have had two um
uh items that revolve around vulnerable
people that
officers haven't even seen fit to uh
look at
the um previous motion from last month
that i put forward about the food banks
not a single
staff member has gone to
the food banks in the district
they're writing excuse me i'm talking
thank you councillor morris i'm going to
have to ask you please to keep to what's
on the agenda i understand
uh it's a preamble it's a preamble if
you'd let me finish we'll get on a lot
quicker
i will i will let you finish provided
it's about this agenda
item right okay let's cut to the chase
then guys
um if we could please go to 3.10.8
now i do believe that the author of this
report sheryl hughes is actually in the
meeting
so this is going to be a question for
sheryl hughes
basically you have stated
that anyone that doesn't agree to a
medical
procedure being done to them should be
seen to um active inde with disorderly
conduct
so are you saying that refusing a
medical procedure
would be disorderly conduct um i did try
and speak to sheryl hughes about this
previously
and uh i guess what i'm now not allowed
to speak to any of the staff
um the the officers seem to be running
this council
so i would ask the author of the report
cheryl hughes
right okay we've got that question
councillor morris thank you
uh miss hughes are you able to answer
that
chairman i'll take that if that's okay
excuse me chairman i've asked the author
the question
thank you mr dalton i would like cheryl
because she's the author of it she will
have
the best knowledge of it she wrote it i
would like cheryl to answer the question
please
thank you chairman the reporters i would
like mr dodson to answer this question
thank you can i ask you the author is he
the author
carry on mr dobson please
thank you sherman um the guidance
set out is based on the government
guidance
um
i haven't said that it's it's law thank
you
i'm going to have to ask you please not
to interrupt you've asked your asked
your question
and now mr dodson is attempting to
answer it please allow that to happen
chairman i asked the question to the
author of the report
you've not even had the
please don't let me lose confidence in
you chairman
i'm sorry councillor boris i'm running
this meeting and mr dodson will answer
the question
apology accepted i'm just reminding you
that you might lose my confidence thank
you
mr johnson thank you chairman
the guidance is set out under 3.10.7
this is guidance and it's based on
government guidance
it's for members to decide um how that
guidance is interpreted it's set out
there
and the report clearly states that there
is an expectation
for staff for member safety the members
would
comply with that guidance it would be
up to the the chairman and up to council
to agree um how they interpret that
um it would be most approved it would be
appropriate for
members not to attend if they're not
willing to to meet that guidance because
it's for the safety of
all who are present at the meeting that
this is a decision for council
this is a report that provides the
information to council to make those
decisions
thank you thank you very much absolutely
i'm not finished sir you cannot enforce
i'm sorry
i've had an opportunity to your question
i'm going to move on
you cannot enforce or coerce medical
procedures on people
it's against the nuremberg i don't think
i don't
think that that is the case if you do
not wish to attend
then you do not know the case i do wish
to attend
and it is my democratic right to attend
i
am not counselor
councillor
thank you chair um first of all i thank
mr dodson for um
the the report um and it members it's no
secret that i'm
a very keen advocate of returning back
to full meetings
um i agree um entirely with councillor
stilts about the daytime
commencement of meetings because it is
going to cause some complexity to those
members that
that do work for all the time and have
other commitments
so i'm going to find it very difficult
to support that
um looking through 3.10.6 for the
options
um i think that you know
looking at the the measures that we
could implement
to have uh covered safe meetings uh
are sound um i think it's absolutely
critical
in the guidance notes the the guidance
under
section two core principles for safety
of council buildings
there's a lot of complexity and
misunderstanding about the two meter
rule
you're allowed two meters or one meter
with mitigations
now mitigation can be a face covering
can be a face shield can be
a provision of seating positioning of
seating
absolutely critical to have ventilation
in the the location where the meeting's
held
people should have their own pen there
should be a sanitizer there there should
be wipes
there could be people who have concerns
about underlying health conditions
the venues could be structured so there
is a two metre standoff to give extra
surety and confidence for those
individual members
and also one metre staggered seating
plans
if if that for members like myself
who feel very comfortable about working
into those areas
i have worked successfully going uh
leaving my house
daily to a place of work with over 200
employees my role is to keep them safe
not just from kobe but in many other
methods
so i'm speaking more from experience
than from passion
i do strongly feel though lateral flow
tests
should be taken by each member in the
afternoon
prior and do you respect chrissy
that that that's a view i think people
should have a lateral flow test
prior in the afternoon before they
attend the meeting
and if the natural flow test is a
demonstration that there is a potential
and that the person could be
cov-positive then obviously that
person's obligated
um not to attend until they've had a pcr
test
so i think that it's really clear for me
that with the range of measures with an
additional
uh suite of measures that i'd be glad to
to table and
assist with with code with secure
protocols we could attend
venues we could have proper meetings
and we could start to get the business
of the business done because we need to
move forward
and finally members i feel very very
very very very strongly about this
because if we prepare to
send our kids to school our key workers
to work
why on earth are we not prepared to go
into an absolute kobe safe
area that i believe the officers would
secure for
them and us and any other attendees
and why wouldn't we do that so i'd
strongly recommend that we return to
full committee meetings
uh in a covert safe environment to be
done and that
meetings are considered to be out of
working hours
thank you chair thank you thank you
councillor councillor
thank you chairman sorry i thought other
people were before me chairman
the hands up but if you want me to speak
now i will
yes i'll take you next yes thank you
thank you chairman
um can i just i think it might be
helpful um
if you uh forgive me chairman but for
members of the public listening to know
regarding uh councillor morris's points
which he referred to that paragraph
so i i go back to that and procedure
rule 10.
um now procedural 10 and i hope i've
interpreted right
i take it that is rule 10 of the
procedures of the council
can i have that confirmed chairman
please it will be yes can you just
confirm that mr dodson
sorry german i can't hear anything no
can you hear me mr johnson
yes that's correct it is correct
but i'm sure that the um the monitoring
officer can
can provide um a model answer on that
okay well i haven't quite finished that
as i know it's now procedural 10
um procedural 10 to me is disorderly
conduct
and it's therefore stating that if
members don't do certain things then
i understand it um it's going to be
misconduct i remember
by persistently disregarding the ruling
of the chairman or by behaving
irregularly
improperly or offensively or by
willfully obstructing
but i took that paragraph to mean
regarding the things to do with having
the lateral flow tests
and everything to check make sure we're
compliant with that
and therefore um i wanted to know how we
would be willfully obstructing the
business of the council
um i'm sure all members are responsible
and if we do move to the full committee
cycle which i have to say
is my desired outcome i do feel that we
need to and i think actually
um at the the meeting where we first had
the first lot of options put before us
there's been some changes in the report
what
since that came forward i'm one of those
that would be supportive of full
committee cycle
with council and uh the um district
planning having passed
the outside venue but the committee
meetings could obviously be held within
the chamber bearing
in mind what the report said but i just
have a bit of trouble with this
disorderly conduct
if medically i can't get into any uh to
the meeting
the picture's all right i
i i can hear you counselor beal
right okay um i'm not quite sure how i
see this
aligning with procedural tennis
disorderly conduct
and therefore not wishing to be as
though i'm trying to make a point
scoring or anything
what assurances will members have then
if members are being told of disorderly
conduct
obviously i have total faith in all the
officers they'd be doing what is
required
but i think if we're gonna have a ruling
for members we need to be clear
that everyone's following the rules and
how would we check that so it's just a
point so i'm clear chairman i'm not
being critical but i don't quite
understand the disorderly conduct if
members don't have lateral flow tests
wearing masks because i'll certainly be
wearing a mask
and i'm sure we'll all be doing what's
necessary but i don't quite get that
alignment
thank you thank you mr dodson would you
like to comment on that
thank you shannon yes
um
who are not speaking make sure that they
are muted please thank you
um sorry yes on the the first point
yes all officers present would be
expected to
um follow the the the guidance
set out and um would be um
more than happy to as far as i'm aware
from from those that we've um
we've spoken to in terms of um
sorry i've taken the report down bear
with me one moment
um as as far as procedure rule 10 and
disorderly
conduct um if if council
were to um agree to this
um recommendation as set out
then uh members would be expected to
abide by and it would be
the chairman down to the chairman to um
enforce that um as i said earlier in
more detail it would be for the
the monitoring officer um for for mr
qualch to give further guidance but he
has
contributed to this report i believe
confirmed that that would be the case
right okay thank you very much
councillor schemes
yes thank you um uh oh sorry
uh uh council channel wants to come back
i want to come back on that
particular point chairman now i've heard
from mr dodson and my point i would
perhaps like the fuller
explanation from mr quelch now hearing
he's had an input into the report
i'm just trying to align members perhaps
not agreeing with the guidance which mr
dodson said was guidance
how the disorderly conduct comes in
which is willfully obstructing the
business of the council
and disregarding the ruling of the
chairman and it seems to do with
um
could you just mute please thank you
very
much sorry cancer china say again yes
well
but disorderly conduct is all about a
member persistently disregarding the
ruling of the chairman
behaving irregularly improperly or
offensively
or by willfully obstructing the business
of the council
and yet we're told it's guidance and i'm
sure all members will be responsible and
do that
i just need to be clear on the
correlation
of why members not doing certain things
will be seen as disorderly conduct
because that has ramifications
right okay um okay i do have a view on
this
uh but did you have anything to add on
that mr dodson
chairman i sought mr quelch to answer mr
duncan sorry
yeah mr crouch uh thank you
thank you chairman yes i did have an
input into that report
um it certainly is um one could say
it's it's a novel use of
procedural 10 and i can understand
members thinking well that that that's
that that's we've never done this before
and that's absolutely true but if you
look at the wording of procedure rule
10 it talks about
two principal things persistently
disregarding the ruling of the chairman
now
i anticipated this is how i imagined it
would go
that council say yes um
flo tests should be carried out
beforehand that's obviously the
responsibility of the councillor
and mass should be worn unless there's a
medical exemption
um now i would imagine chairman that you
would therefore
ask members to confirm that they have
carried out a test they don't have to
say what
test was but you would you would at
least be wanting them to confirm they've
carried out a test
and they've acted on that test now if
they are not prepared to give you that
that assurance then you can say well
then
you should be leaving this meeting
because you have not double checked
that you will not be spreading a disease
to other people
the second point is the word improperly
now
where councils already decided that
they're going to follow the government
guidance
and as a public authority of the slaves
as a public authority it would be
expected
that this council would follow
government guidance
on keeping everybody safe and avoiding
the spreading of the disease
then for a member not to follow that
would be improper as well
because council's already determined so
this
on two limbs of procedure rule 10
i would say that that means the rest of
procedural 10
can operate thank you
i i think i'd better make my point um
quite clear that there has to be
an element of cooperation uh by all
councillors
uh and staff we haven't done this before
the reason that we're having lateral
flow tests
the reason that we are having
inoculations or
vaccines and the reasons that we're
wearing masks
is for the safety of themselves
and others and i would certainly expect
counsellors and staff
to look after themselves and each other
i'm going to go now to councillor
schemes
thank you chair um well um picking up on
council morris's point
um there is an issue here with these
rules i think we have to accept it
uh the for example the idea that we
should all wear masks except when we're
speaking which is when we're actually
projecting potential
um pieces of covered
is counterintuitive uh and also there is
the uh and i know that in certain
councillors cases
they don't actually believe that uh
covered was a thing
now i know the government believes
something entirely different and i agree
with the government
entirely on this but it does create a
problem
and what i fear is we're going to reach
a point
at which we have a vital meeting to be
held
which will be disrupted because somebody
refuses
and they have the right to refuse to
believe that the government is correct
in their analysis
and therefore will refuse to wear a mask
and you as chair will be forced to
uh if that happens you will be forced to
take action
and that could cause some serious
disruption so i think you need to think
up
hard about that and and have plans in
place to mitigate that if that is the
way things unfold
i would um because you could view it as
willful obstruction of the council
if somebody doesn't wear a mask uh but
there are issues with this and i can
understand
uh uh both sides of the point of view
also um the requirement for lateral flow
tests
some of us have had double vaccinations
is it necessary to have a lateral flow
test after a double
vaccination well i'm
i'm no medical expert but what i can say
is if you have
uh either one vaccine or two vaccines
it does not mean to say that you will
not get it and it doesn't mean to say
that you cannot pass it on to others
and that's why you should have a lateral
flow test
all the vaccine will do if you like if
it's raining all the vaccine will do
will put an overcoat on you to stop
you getting wet but it won't stop other
people
so
there's other scientific arguments that
would contradict that
that would say that in fact like the cdc
in america are basically saying that if
you've been double vaccinated
then the chances are infinitesimal of
passing it of contracting and then
passing it on
but i understand that this is the
government's point of view
and we're probably going and we're going
to have to accord to it but i do
take into you know people who've been
discussing this ad nauseam for
ages and it and the and the whole of
this uh
uh pandemic has caused a lot of mental
stress to a lot of people
uh so i'm just simply saying that that
there are two sides to this
though i understand we have to accord
with the government's
instructions thank you very much council
of passenger next
thank you mr chairman um i would like to
say that i
concur with uh council of stilts i think
um
uh meeting in the daytime is certainly
going to stop me coming
for quite a few of the days i mean i can
jiggle around things but there's only so
much and i do have to go to work so
i'm one of those that probably wouldn't
be coming
and i'd also like to say i agree with
councillor morris i'm not prepared to
take
um these tests which are totally flawed
uh and the same with the mars again you
know put a mask on when you're not
speaking take it off when you are
speaking i mean
i know every one of us is a scientist
based on the bbc
but let's be honest it's nonsense what's
going on i'm not saying covet is
nonsense
but the things we are doing to protect
ourselves
it's nonsense you know do your hands one
day
wear gloves another day wash your
shopping
i mean wake up smell the coffee let's
say
you know i do believe in covid but let's
be sensible
so if those of you that want to wear a
spacesuit and go to meetings it's
cool by me but then you should provide
another room
for those of us who are maybe less
frightened
and sort of a bit more realistic about
what a virus is
and how it performs it doesn't it
doesn't come out of a night time and
just go in pubs
it doesn't just behave like this you
can't take a mask off and put it on
and that's your protection every time
you wear a mask you should throw it away
you should have loads of them you know
so there is a logic so
for one i would be somebody who wouldn't
be paid
to take a flow test because i think
they're flawed which they are
but then again that's just my opinion of
course mask thing i don't agree with i
think that causes more problems than
they're worth i've had throat cancer i
certainly wouldn't want to wear a dirty
mask
for two hours breathing my own breath in
and out
so that would be another thing that
stopped me from coming so
you know it sort of singles me out the
next thing will be the jab
you know pin a yellow star on me or
something as somebody that hasn't been
jabbed
well that's my opinion you know i don't
want to be jabbed i don't want
something which i've got no idea what it
is being put into my veins by somebody
who doesn't know what they're doing i
think i appreciate that i don't i don't
want this to turn into a bait about
about kovid i just want to keep to the
the question about whether we accept
these recommendations or not so thank
you very much
can i move now to councillor councillor
swain please
yes thank you chairman um
for one thing um i wonder whether we
just leave
out the reference to procedural 10. uh
but secondly we're talking about
arrangements for conducting council
business
where councillors um have to respect the
other councillors and if that involves
taking certain uh precautions against um
passing on
a virus uh then they they should um
they should be undertaken um
we could um however i want to talk about
the proposals for meetings
um in view of what has been said by
councillors still
lagging uh perhaps mr dodson can say
whether there is any possibility
of an outside venue for an evening
meeting
uh of council
can i just stop you there i think mr
dodson might want to come back on one of
those points mr dodson
yes thank you chairman um i just wanted
to point out that the 11 a.m
was solely for the statutory annual
meeting
that that was being um proposed and that
was because of the the availability of
the event of the venue
um that was the preferred venue um that
could be used that isn't available
um in the evenings so it would just be
for for that meeting
uh initially um obviously if we went to
um
have committee meetings that were held
within the chamber
then they could be held um consistently
at six o'clock the same as
as meetings are held now i did just want
to
to respond on you know a couple of the
the other issues if i if i may
particularly the
cast council bas councillor bassinger
raised
sorry um the idea of having two rooms
was one that
is not possible because of the um
the guidance from government that we
can't hold it in separate rooms and
stream it which is why it would be much
better for everybody if
it was streamed because we wouldn't be
having to face um
these issues um and i equally respect
you know everybody has different views
on this but
as officers we have to follow the
government guidance and put that
that into the report and we also have a
duty
of care for um officers and anta members
um when we write this to to put in the
government guidance it's
what we have to follow as officers
and have to respect and um you know i
have real concerns
um that we can't put officers in a
position regardless of
of people's views where we're not
following um
government guidance because we're
responsible for their health and safety
thank you okay yes you've got you've got
one minute left
um right well give me this
only one meeting in the year and may
never occur again i agree with the
proposal on the 11 o'clock
start for the the statutory annual
meeting
i think all the committees can meet in
the chamber
except um district planning
and for that i would suggest we we have
a
um cut down uh membership
of four from each of the area planning
chair vice chair and two others to
operate rather than trying to hold
external meetings for
district planning um as
far as the council committees are
concerned i think
or as much material as possible should
go through
those committees um and if as
i think is reasonable for the short term
and we are talking about matter of a few
months
we operate with an interim management
group
um then they should they should limit
themselves
to only urgent matters that need to be
decided on but
as council uh in the light of what
can i just can i just stop you there
counselor are you making that
are you making that as a as an amendment
to the proposal
um yes that's an amendment regarding
district planning
um otherwise uh i agree with the other
recommendations and i agree with the
interim measures group short term
we are only talking about a few months
and the annual statutory meeting is a
one-off
okay uh if that is a proposal is that
seconded by
do i have a second up
chairman can you listen to the rest of
the debate
yes yes i'm quite quite happy to do
quite happy to do that
um counselor none i think is next
i'm not sure i was chairman but i'm
happy to go if you want me to
understand i haven't got i haven't got
an order i've got a list of names of
everybody but so i'm happy to hear from
you first
thank you i'm probably um being a bit
old-fashioned here chairman but
uh until retirement i spent as you know
40 years working for a local authority
and
i always had it drummed into me that you
ignored
government guidance at your peril and
indeed sometimes the guidance was
classed as statutory guidance
and i do feel sorry for the officers
over this to be quite honest with you
because
they're between a rock and a hard place
this for me is not about
personal views about the covid
or about vaccinations it's not about
personal views
it's about following government guidance
and we are an emanation
of the government whether we like it or
not we're a tier
of government and we should follow
government guidance
and i believe that there are there's
built-in
sections within 310 7 that allow
for bona fide exemptions
for example on masks if you look at
little bullet
two under 3107 it says
unless exempt so that there is a
there are elements of built in exemption
so my personal view
about this is that we should follow the
guidance of the government of this
country and
the job is difficult enough for officers
at the moment as it is
and i think we need to get the statutory
meeting done and we need to get it done
at 11
and we need to get it done in a venue
which allows us to be safe
thank you very much um councillor siddal
thank you chairman
what we need to to think about in terms
of this is
the practicality of it and ensuring that
we operate
as in the best possible way as as a
council and that everybody has their
democratic rights
one of the things that in terms of
enforcing
anybody who isn't abiding by the rules
that have been stipulated
i think that's going to be extremely
difficult to enforce
how who's going to manage that situation
if someone doesn't
abide by the the guidelines that we've
got there
uh we know from experience that it's
very difficult
to remove a member from the chamber
so yeah we would be in a similar
situation
if something like that had to happen
again
in terms of the meetings
this is a an ongoing process it's not
this isn't a one-off process
this is the first stage in us coming
back as a council to meetings
the guidelines and the rules will change
on june the 21st
so what we've got to do is ensure that
this
keeps changing along with any guidelines
that come from the government
so this is the stage that we're at the
moment this is the the point that we're
at the moment
in terms of wearing masks we really
should be wearing masks all the time
we're going to wear them
wear them all the time in the chamber or
wherever we're meeting
the uh i think it counts the bastard's
point that taking the mask off to speak
is probably yeah if you if you if you
it's probably the worst thing to do
we know now that covid is an airborne
disease
and it's not to do with surfaces so the
key thing is is is controlling the air
in any room that we're in uh
cavity cannot be picked up from touching
a surface that's been proven in lots of
research now
um if if the statute annual if it's a
one-off and that's the only meeting
that's going to be held at 11 o'clock
that's fine i am concerned however
at meetings staying at 6 00 before covid
we had meetings at half past seven
having meetings at 6 00 pm
actually makes it very difficult for all
of us that do still have a job
having to finish work and having to get
to the council offices for a lot of
members
for six pm is going to be virtually
impossible
so if we're going to have committed
meetings back
in the chamber then that needs to be
really at the
earliest 7 p.m and not 6 p.m
um or back to what it used to be which
is half past 7.
and i think that we need to go back to
the fall
as councillor channel said we need to go
back to
the full committee processes with all
the committees reinstated
thank you thank you very much i've got
um
three more names tara can you help me
i've got councillor right sean and c and
thompson what order
they did they come in i've got
councillor thompson council shawnee
council fluker councillors white council
jarvis councillor boyce councillor
durham chairman
thank you and councillor morris your
council morris wanted to come back
chairman
thank you okay uh councillor thompson
next please
um thank you chairman i'll try and be
brief
i can't help but agree with um
nearly everything that's been said some
of some of the guidance some of the
rules
are downright bizarre um i'm massively
disappointed as i imagine lots of us are
that we can't just carry on virtually
as you can in scotland and wales you
know we're obliged to attend these
meetings if we wish to
carry out our democratic functions but
we can't choose to go into a coffee shop
um but i do think
you know it beholds all of us to try and
protect everyone else as far as we can
and while i'm not
a covic warrior i do have a husband
partway through
um a course of radiotherapy so he's in
you know compromised
um i'm sure we have other members who
um are vulnerable in some ways i'm
equally sure we probably have officers
who are
but that said how do we know that
someone who said they've had a negative
test actually has and i'm not saying
anyone's gonna lie but
we don't know we don't know if people
who have ma who aren't wearing masks uh
bonafide exempt any more than you do
when you see someone wandering around
the supermarket
the whole thing's a mess so i'm just
going to ask members
please can we just try and look off
after everybody else especially the
staff because
you know they don't really have a choice
um can we do our best to support
everyone um
i will in fact second councillor swain's
proposal to have a
slightly cut down district um planning
committee not necessarily because i
agree with it but
you know he's made he put the idea
forward i think it should
be debated and i'll second it to get it
on the table
um that's about it really i mean
no no one likes any of this but can we
please try and work together
so that we can get back to the full
committee cycle as soon as possible
which is
what i think we should do thank you
chairman thank you councillor thompson
councillor shawnee
thank you chairman um
uh councillor thompson has just um
touched a wee bit on what i've got to
say
um because we need to be aware of all
the evidence
um going forward and the lateral flow
tests
are mentioned in the text and i would
just like to point out that there is
much
scientific evidence that there are
false positives and false negatives
um um to do with with this test
and so it does need to be taken into
consideration
um should this be uh the tests that
people are required
uh to take that's all i wanted to say at
the moment chairman thank you
thank you councillor sean c councillor
fluker next
thank you chairman i i i mean i've sat
here listening
to all of the members speaking about
their own concerns so you'll have to
excuse me
if i talk about our customers and our
residents and democracy
um chairman if you uh if i could just
take your attention to
page 12 and in particular measure four
which speaks to 60 peoples uh
allowed in the venue now one presumes
that includes some kind of staff
from the venue and in our own staff
and 31 members although i do sympathize
with those that might not be able to
make it 11 o'clock
in the morning so um perhaps mr
mr dodson or or miss hughes
could tell me how they are actually
going to manage this because this is
democracy you can't say to people who
want to come to a a
council meeting whether it's the
statutory annual it's one of those
complicated uh planning issues which i
think we'll be facing
soon at the district planning committee
and say look we're
so sorry but we can't let you in because
there is no room
so mr dodson how are you going to
implement that thank you
thank you councillor fluker mr dodson
you want to come back on that
thank you through you chairman um public
attendance can be via youtube
whilst whilst the meeting can't be held
um virtually the public attendance can
be
via youtube and we would be streaming it
to ensure that
the public have sight of the democracy
happening
thank you chairman would you like me to
come back because yeah
although i think the question
i'm sorry chairman i spoke over the top
of you and i apologize but did you say i
can come back
you can come back although i think the
question has been i just wanted to pick
up on something that mr dodson said
earlier
um and i think he said he was
disappointed by virtue of the fact that
so many people
have had logged on virtually to watch
council meetings and and i agree with
you
um you know if you do your benchmarking
this is not uh
this isn't just not malden district
council it's all district councils
and it's all councils throughout the
country uh at
all levels so um that's a great answer
and i'm
pleased to to hear it um
but can you tell me what you are doing
um so that moving forward and when we
move out of the
the coveted regulations or to the next
extension of them where we're going next
um what you're going to do to
live stream all council meetings so that
members of the public
can actually watch it and listen to it
thank you
mr dobson would you like to reply to
that yes thank you
chairman um yes we are looking at um
hybrid meetings
um and the possibility to hold those
if legislation allows which would enable
members to be
either present or not and also for all
meetings to be streamed
live to the public as well thank you
very much okay
i'm going next to councillor jarvis
councillor jarvis
yeah thank you chairman sorry is having
a bit of a problem there
um thank you i i just wanted to comment
briefly as far
as the uh 11 o'clock issue is concerned
uh it's uh i'm one of the people who's
working and working back in london very
shortly
uh it's not ideal but i do understand
the complications of
of organizing a meeting where we
obviously want everybody or most people
to attend
as many as possible because it's a
statutory annual meeting um
i think uh i i think somebody did just
ask the question
is there an alternative to the 11
o'clock start i don't think there's one
in the paper so i think it's uh
i would be interested to know if there
is an alternative being put forward so
that everybody could attend
i'm a bit old-fashioned you know when i
see a time in the diary for a meeting
i organized my sort of work around that
and then we'll make sure i can make that
time
when the time changes that can cause
complications that happens to be a very
busy day for me but i will obviously try
and reorganize
i would like officers to say is there an
alternative to 11 o'clock
so perhaps we can all make it or not
um and the only other comments i've got
with regards to the other options that
are in the paper going forwards for
regular meetings i think the interim
measures committee
option uh has the right balance of risk
compared to member involvement so that
would certainly be the one that would
have my support with regards to guidance
and expectations uh
i think we could be all night discussing
these and obviously there are lots of
views
and understandably lots of different
views i'm very happy to go along with
any sort of sensible reasonable
uh um proposal on that so chairman if i
could just have an answer on the
is there another option to 11 o'clock or
not that would be
appreciated thank you mr dodson is there
an alternative
time to 11 o'clock please
yes thank you chairman the the 11
o'clock was the recommendation made by
the
the officer group um that sat on this
there could be some some flexibility
around that we
would need to be out of the the venue
and cleared by 6 p.m
um and we know that the when we had the
statutory
meeting in november it went on a very
long time
um i would suggest that we started by
1pm
maybe latest to enable the full meeting
to happen and to be cleared up but there
would be a bit of flexibility
around that yes what i can say
is that the meeting won't go on after
three hours because uh
the council has already decided that
that's the length of the meetings
council jarvis do you want to come back
on that if i may just yes i mean if the
meeting
can't be held in the evening which would
be my preference
um then if it is to be held in the day
frankly the sooner the better so
11 o'clock or earlier um from my point
of view so i think anybody who is
working
uh might just you know take half a day
off and be able to do the other half at
work might be a consideration so
but obviously i realize people have got
to get the meeting organized and there's
probably a lot of logistics so
it's a one-off meeting so we'll probably
all do all that we can to make it but
i'm certainly not suggesting it should
be later
in the day 11 o'clock or earlier or held
in the evening when it was originally
scheduled
would be my point i think the only other
thing chairman if i may say councillor
civil made a very good point about 7 30
meetings
hello for all of us who work we all
signed up as councillors
with a sort of time knowing when council
meetings are going to take place
six o'clock i work in london six o'clock
means i'll be taking a lot of half days
off i think uh
serious consideration should be given to
the future for those meetings taking
place when when
at 7 30 it might not be as convenient
for officers and i do understand or
forget other people coming
but that's what we signed up to and i
think further consideration should be
given to reverting back
to 7 30. thank you for indulging me
jenna thank you very much
um councillor boyce next
um thank you chairman um i i've not got
a problem with
uh any flow tests i've had dozens
recently
um or um wearing a mask
although i don't believe they're
effective at all
um my logic for that is that when i
got a mask on and off and got in my car
and forgotten to take the mask off and i
put my
glasses on the glass is missed up which
says to me that that my
plume is going everywhere anyway um
but i wear the mask not to protect
myself
but to protect others and i i believe
that is the correct thing to do if it's
uh some discomfort to me so be
i'll put up with that now uh a matter of
procedure
um chairman um can i assume
i don't know whether mr question whether
you can answer this
um from your knowledge or mr quest might
be required
can i assume that as we changed our
constitution
to have reality meetings there is
nothing
to stop us dropping straight back
into our old um constitution or will we
need to have some sort of amendments to
it
in which case there's not a lot of time
between now and a couple of weeks time
thank you chairman thank you council
voices
that's a fair point can you help us with
that mr quelch
uh i can chairman yes um we had
anticipated that particular
scenario arising that we would have to
go back to
physical meetings and so the
constitution has been drafted
so that um there are rules for those
meetings that are physical and rules for
those that are remote
so there needs to be no change and in
fact keeping the remote part
of the constitution is useful because if
the government do make legislation that
allows remote meetings then
we we can we can operate procedurally
whether there are physical meetings or
whether there are remote meetings
okay thank you very much um councillor
darren
yeah thank you very much chairman i
think we are making a meal of this
aren't we
look the quicker we restore the
democratic process for the benefit of
our residents the better
absolutely the case um councillor siddal
is absolutely right
there's a there's no reason to have
evening meetings in face to face at six
o'clock and as councillor jarvis has
said
it makes it almost impossible for those
that work so i cannot
see any logical reason when we return
back to face-to-face meetings that they
shouldn't be at
at 7 30 as they have always been
um and as councillor silla said this is
a this is
short term we don't know how short term
i mean we won't know until the 10th of
may whether the
openings on the 17th of may will go
ahead as planned and we don't know
what is going to come after the 21st of
june
we don't know whether mask is still
going to be required we don't know
whether social distancing is going to be
required
but we do owe it to our electorate to
uh to restore the democratic process
um in terms of 11 o'clock meetings yes
it's not ideal for some members but
you know county council meetings every
single one is during the day so you have
to cut your cloth accordingly and if you
want to be a county councillor then you
have to be prepared to
to attend daytime meetings and in terms
of
of the requirements to uh take a lateral
flow test or to show an inoculation i
mean there are certain countries in the
world that you are legally
required to have things like yellow
fever jabs and certain inoculations
well if you don't want to have those
inoculations you don't go to those
countries it's
it's personal choice and if the law says
or if guidance says that you should have
tests or you should have a coveted
vaccination to access
be it pubs or wherever well
you you make your choice accordingly
don't you so chairman
i cannot support the reintroduction of
of
the an interim measures group we do
require
um the full democratic process involving
as many elected members at meetings as
can be facilitated
thank you so much thank you very much
um councillor white i don't think you've
spoken yet have you
no mr chairman i haven't um well firstly
i'd like to say i mean
myself along with probably lots of other
members i've been very ill for the last
15 months but a lot of time in and out
of hospitals so i absolutely support
these measures in fact i think they're
vital
whether they're going to be effective or
not i don't know but i think we have to
get them done and i think we have to
have a process in place to
to check and police these issues because
we need to keep officers members and
members of the public safe it's vitally
important and i think
wearing a mask in a little throat test
might be uncomfortable but
absolutely worth every second but the
other concern i've had is i keep going
through this paperwork and i've not seen
it mentioned unless i'm missing it about
these 6 p.m starts in the physical
meeting
and i have to say this if this is in
there this needs to be removed because i
certainly i struggle to get home for 6
p.m and there's no way i could get to a
physical
meeting by 6 p.m you know i don't mind
giving up a day if it's a daytime
meeting
but for every single evening meeting to
have to um leave early is ridiculous so
is it in the paperwork and is it
possible to get it removed because i
have other than that i agree with all
the recommendations
other than that particular point right
thank you very much
um i know that um we've already had a a
a
an intimation of a proposal by
councillor siddall but
uh i i think that this map that this
particular matter has been discussed
i've heard
pretty much everybody speak i'm going to
move to the amendments now
uh there was a proposal by councillor
swain to have um cut down committees
uh that was seconded by councillor
thompson uh and what i'd like to do is
if councillor swain
did you want to say anything about that
uh amendation as the uh
proposer
well the point to change is
to minimize the need for
giant expensive meetings externally
in the same way that with all of members
meeting
we can stand it for the annual statutory
meeting which is vital
but for the short term i would have
thought we could
handle district planning
issues in a more balanced way and
reduced
in a proper committee in the chamber all
right i just want to
i just want to go back to mr dodson
who's got an update on the timings
mr dodson yes thank you chairman
the the timings are based on
council approved the schedule of
meetings
for the year now this was based on the
the time when we were were undertaking
the
online meetings um but the schedule that
was approved by members
were for meetings to start at 6 00 p.m
so
that is what is in the schedule at the
moment hence my reference earlier it
wasn't in these papers
but hence my reference to to 6 p.m
because that is
what's been approved by council
presently
um i would just further add the the the
meetings
do require um more support from staff
in terms of the streaming and the
there's additional member support
required for for meetings currently so
that would be
um a staff pressure um on
evening meetings but i fully recognize
that that previously
we supported evening meetings um because
that that that's the way it was but it
would be slightly more staff resource
required
thank you yes i i understand that um but
i
i can you know i think as councillor
jarvis said we
initially we were having a evening
meetings and uh if we're looking to go
back to normal
so councillor swain your uh proposal
for uh these cut down committees which
i'm going to take a vote on in a moment
um can you just it happens for the damn
vice chairman and two others from each
of the area committees to constitute
the district planning meeting until the
um
uh until we can meet as a full
council right okay so you're saying that
the chairman the vice chairman and two
others four from each is that correct
yes that's the idea right council of the
thomas
sorry i missed that that which would
which could be managed in the chamber
right councillor thompson you originally
seconded that
are you happy with that proposal
i think it should be voted on i must say
at this point
i'm not going to support it i could say
that i didn't necessarily support it
um but i will leave the second thing in
there and we'll see what comes a bit i'm
getting a lot of nodding heads i'm
shaking heads i don't think this is
going anywhere to be honest
right okay uh now i'm going to go around
again i
only want people to speak on this
amendment please
um mr crouch did you
want to say something
yeah thank you thank you sorry chairman
just to clarify
the motion put forward by councillor
swain when does he want this to take
effect
because there is a district council
planning uh
committee meeting planned um for
before the 6th of may when obviously
things change
so does he wish this to take effect
immediately or does he have another date
in mind in other words post the 6th of
may
yeah okay um
council swain could you just briefly
answer that question because i've got
two more speakers on the original
original amendment well it would only
apply
after the 6th of may um if there's a
district planning meeting before that it
it would be a virtual one anyway
wouldn't it
so that can be as um all these virtual
meetings have been
um the other end point then would be
when um
uh the coverage restrictions allow
full membership in the chamber
okay um before we go any further um i
i've got two people who haven't spoken
yet on the original
recommendations that's councillor
fleming and councillor staff so can i go
so i'll take the leader last uh could i
ask councillor fleming to speak please
yes thank you chair
i wanted to speak about councillors or
could i just pause you there
point of order counsellor voice
um yes chairman it it it
is consistent with my previous uh
question
if you're going to change the makeup of
a
of a committee that will need proper
um advertising to the public
and it should be not something that can
be done tonight
okay um i'm sorry to interrupt you
chairman but
um i yeah i agree with
um with council voice i think
we are wrong to put this and i was wrong
to say therefore i withdraw my
second apologies to council this way
okay i understand that thank you for
that
um in in that case is that
before i go for a second could i just
ask councillor fleming
to uh to speak on the first
three recommendations councillor fleming
thank you chair
no i wanted to speak about councillor
swain's amendment
i just wanted to say that i disagreed
strongly with it um
i wanted to make the point that actually
district planning has been cancelled
since november we haven't sat at a
district planning committee since
november
so if there's suddenly a backlog of
business now i'm afraid that's most
unfortunate
but the last five have been cancelled
thank you
all right thank you leader
thank you mr chairman i actually
agree with the recommendations except
for the 7
30 start i think we do need to go back
and um i think it was councillor durham
and cancer siddal
spoke very eloquently and said you know
this is it's because it's changing we
have to go through we have to go
with government government government
guidance
and i totally do don't want the meetings
to start at six i'm sorry if it's an
inconvenience to the officers
and i know it will be and i know how
hard they've worked but i think it
needs to go back to 7 30. and my main
concern is how we're going to deal
with the interruption which may be
possible which was raised by cancer
schemes and packages
that if we go to do the statutory annual
um and i won't mention
anybody's name in particular but what
can we
do because there's no point in us all
going to a meeting
unless it can can take place
because it is a waste of council money
whether it be 600 pounds or a thousand
pounds or whatever
and as far as i'm concerned the council
businesses
the council business would be disrupted
so i would actually ask that we either
get a little bit more guidance from
mr quelch um because there is no point
in
taking having and attending an annual
meeting
which is not going to take place for
whatever reasons whether we agree with
whoever has said
what i personally feel we should take
responsibility and make sure everybody's
safe
i certainly didn't want to go back to
face-to-face meetings which i made quite
clear
at the previous meeting but i will do
the same because it is as i think
councillor fluke said democracy we have
to look after our residents
and we should be seen to do what we can
and this at this council if you don't
want to work together
there's no point where you work together
because we tried to do the best from our
residents and i think it's really
important
that we try to do this tonight and but
also respect the views
of other councillors who share a
different one from ours
but also those those views that you do
share that are different from ours
i would ask that you respect our views
as well
thank you mr chair thank you leader
so i'm going to go back to councillor
swain
your uh with the proposal for
the cut down committees councillor uh
thompson has removed her second
of that proposal is there another
seconder for
these reduced numbers uh
chairman uh um in view of the lack of
support generally i don't think there's
any point in going through a vote on it
so i will um
okay that's fine thank you uh the second
proposal was
from councillor civil which one and uh
he would like to take the committees
back
to 7 30. uh councillor siddal
yeah so my my proposal is and
and the first well i'm going to give two
separate proposals
the first is in terms of the full
council is that we move
that the strategy annual we hold that
meeting
at 9 30 in the morning
which will then give a three hour
meeting
and then people can return to work those
that work
in the afternoon for the full uh for the
the accounts the committee meetings the
return of the committee meetings that
they are
moved to 7 30 in the evening
so there's two proposals one that the
statutory annual takes place
at 9 30 starts at 9 30 in the morning so
they're finished
by 12 30. so i'll be there cancer it
won't be a new proposal this will be an
amendment full amendment yeah
there are two amendments thank you there
are two amendments
one for the 9 30.
a proposition on the uh on the table yet
so
councillor siddal's proposal would be
the substantive proposal
chairman we did i didn't councillor
may's second did it at this
it has been there has been secretary
council voice thank you
carry on councillor siddal so so it is
so basically
we're going in terms of the options
uh we are going for the
in terms of three point 10.6
we're moving to return to full council
cycle with meetings larger than 17
staff in the council chamber at 7 30 and
then we're going for
the statutory annual which is part of
the original recommendation
to be held at 9 30 in the morning rather
than 11
a.m right okay um
i need to go back to mr dodson first of
all i see other hands
mr dodson
thank you chairman um just to advise i
think
the from advice by by officers the setup
time
for the external venue would be about
two hours
in terms of putting all of the it and
everything in place
for it so could i respectfully ask for
ten o'clock
to so that they're not starting too
early and that still allows a one
o'clock finish
i think that's acceptable we have to
come up with a compromise that works for
everybody
right so so sorry proposal one is a ten
o'clock
start and the second proposal
is on 10 points on
on 10.6 is it on the table
that we return to uh
we returned to four committee cycles
physically
um and they start at 7 30 in the evening
right okay uh so uh
does that need seconding councillor maze
i'll second that proposal
okay that's been second i've i've got
several uh
speakers chairman chairman this excludes
the district planning
committee i think
exclu excludes the district planning
committee why would that be councillor
boyce
um the committees are going to be held
in the council chamber the district
planning committee can't be
so that would that would be held like
the statutory union wouldn't it
that would that would be an outside that
would be an outside venue okay
um right i've got several several hands
there
um tara could you just advise me of the
order please
and i'll try and write them down uh yes
simon of course
um i've got council morris wanting to
come back
then councillor durham uh council
siddell still got his hand up but
i'm not sure if that's still relevant
and council lagging
and council mrs channel so i've got
councillor morris councillor lagan
council mrs channel the others have
removed their hands
thank you very much councillor
councillor morris this will be on the
amendment please
um i'd just like to add an amendment to
the amendment and possibly an amendment
on that amendment
if that's possible um i'd like to just
say
why has no one given consideration to
the outdoor
[Music]
venues we have promenade park riverside
park
even the courtyard morgan district
council offices
surely we could uh do something with an
outdoor venue which would uh
obviously minimize any spread of the
scandemic i mean
uh um covid um
what has no consideration been given to
using one of our own
outdoor venues it's may we could uh
we could meet up outside at the end of
it we could uh
maybe do a pims or clock and maybe a
crochet crochet or bowls or something
all right okay i understand that uh
i i think i'm not arguing against the
point but
uh we can't rely on the weather and
unfortunately we can't stream outside
so um outside i do it all the time
councillor durham
chairman it was a legacy hand it has
been removed but
um i look we're only talking but we have
one district planning meeting which is
next week before the deadline
so let's get that out the way the chance
of us having another one i sincerely
hope between then
and the 21st of june is slim so
let's just get on with it please
okay thank you for that counselor
thank you chair yeah i just was to do
with the uh the recommendation the
amendment chair
and the recommendation c hasn't been
included in the recommendation
and i'd suggest that that is one of the
most critical points
that this council does choose to adopt
the suite of recommendations that the
officers have
detailed and put in because this is a
pandemic
i apologize for the 127 000 people who
have suffered deaths
um because of kovid by some of my other
members comments
i'm very saddened by that and i know
myself i've been touched by
people who have been taken with this
awful disease
but i would like to ensure share that we
do
adopt a comprehensive suite of measures
as per the officers and put in there
yes i i can confirm that
c is included as as part of the uh
of the original um proposal uh which was
seconded by councillor maize
councillor chana next um thank you
chairman
um i'd just like to say i'm speaking on
the amendment um
i i will support it i i will do anything
to help get the statutory annual going
and the committee cycle
returned so i will support the 7 30
and if the 10 o'clock suits um members
and officers i will go
um with that chairman my question
regarding uh the procedure 10
i've had that answer that i wanted i
needed to understand the correlation of
the procedure
um regarding the guidance i think all
members will make them ask i will
because i have my husband
and myself who need to consider various
things so i just wanted to be clear on
that
but one thing i would like to say that's
not with the amendment chairman
i have recently checked out because i
was concerned about the district
planning on the 5th of may and my
understanding is it's been cancelled
yet people are referring to it taking
place so i think we all need to be clear
that the district planning and council
fleming's right
they've all been cancelled so i believe
it's not taking place
and i go back to my my initial statement
when i said i wanted
my desire was for full return to
committee it is democratic
um i'm happy with the time and quite
frankly i did make the point that that
would mean full council and district
planning outside venue
so that's i think what we've got on the
table and i will be sorting supporting
the amendment chairman um with that
agreement thank you council chennai i
can confirm
that the meeting of the fifth of may has
been cancelled the district planning
meeting and i believe that's been moved
to the 13th of may
thursday the 13th of may right okay
so we um so tara could i just
ask are you clear on the uh amendments
i'm being told that uh sorry that that
has not been rescheduled yet
okay um so tara are you clear on the
amendment so far
yes kevin is it possible to have them up
on the screen at all
yes thank you
um
while we're waiting on that um i do uh i
do thank members for
your involvement i think this has been
uh very well debated
uh oh here it is now so
uh as you can see a that we
moving the statutory annual meeting to
the start time
of uh 11 a.m sorry 10 a.m
to allow for this to take place at an
outside venue
that members review the future meeting
options in section 310
6 and identify the preferred option and
that is that the council returns to full
committee cycle
physically with meetings larger than 17
members and staff
off-site and within the number held
in the chamber with meetings starting at
7 30 p.m and that is having regard to
the risks set out in
appendix a and accept any cost
which will be a budget pressure for the
year
c remains unchanged other than
the removal of section 3 10
7 and the guidance
as you can see is there
i think i think we're about there that's
what we're voting on
a v and c um
so i'm satisfied that everyone who
wishes to speak
has now done so so
first of all i'll ask we can either go
to the vote
or we can agree those by a cent
before the vote
record the vote okay that's what we do
is that second
second second council amaze
thank you can uh tara in that case could
i ask you to take
uh the vote please
uh yes chairman just to clarify members
this is the vote for the
greedy amendment and then obviously we
would need to vote again to agree that
the substantive ones that
does that make sense chairman yes thank
you
okay so let's just indicate if you're
full
against or abstaining and when i
um call your name and that's for the
amendment as i just had on the screen
so starting with councillor bassinger
please
four yes
[Music]
[Music]
thank you councillor edwards four
[Music]
that's the helm
that's the keys four
you can't
this violates the nuremberg code against
castle none four
council shawnee four thank you
councillor
four falling asleep then you count the
schemes
four that's a stamp four
four that's a swing
and no abstentions thank you
that is agreed uh then thank you very
much for that members
so chairman do you now want members to
vote on the actual
substantive motion yes yes please
uh um could you just remind us of that
again please tara
yeah i put that up on the screen again
bear with me um just to clarify also um
mr dodson did make reference to a review
i wasn't sure if
that we wanted to actually refer to that
in recommendations
okay can we just have a look at the
recommendation first please
if i just
right so this is the uh
this is the original
um
recommendation as a men did chairman as
the
the amendments have just been agreed by
the council
[Music]
right okay so uh i'm sorry can you can
you help me with this
uh mr crouch
is this this is to be agreed well that's
right now you
you councillors need to vote on the
amended um original motion
so um yes you now need to go through
unless members are going to agree by
ascent
general assent um then you'd have to
take a roll call again
now to actually um
play that newly amended
motion yes so so i see right
okay i i think this is the same same
thing as we
voted for before is it not mr crouch
well it's with the amendment yes you
you've already had a vote on the
amendment
um and and now the amendment takes the
place of the original motion
so now members need to actually resolve
whether they accept the motion as
amended
right okay that's fine okay in that case
um taraka uh i understand that uh
there's been a call for another recorded
vote and that's been seconded by
councillor bell so we'll now go for the
uh roll call please joan
chairman before we do the vote do you
mind can i just seek a bit of
clarification on one point
in terms of the inter thank you in terms
of the timing
i understand the 730 and i'm fully
behind that but obviously that's only
for
meetings that can be held in the chamber
so if there are meetings where there's a
greater number than
17 uh there's no sort of
are we sort of assuming that it would be
held they would also be held at ten
o'clock
we don't specifically state that but is
that an assumption just wanted members
to be
aware of that i think i think the ten
o'clock
is is purely for the statutory annual
yes that's my point really chairman i
mean i understand at the moment
it says that but uh number b
on here refers to holding full council
meetings
uh in the chamber um but if we were
going to hold
off site meetings um there's no
stipulation as to what sort of time
uh what well is there an assumption
being made that they would also
be held off site at 7 30 which is what
it currently states
and if that is the case that's fine by
me but i think if mr dodson had a
problem with
holding off-site meetings at 7 30 now
would be a good time to say
i think you're right mr dodson would you
like to
explain how we would be able to do this
perhaps yes thank you
chairman it was the the meeting was
scheduled for the 20th of may for the um
statutory annual and we need to do it
before the end of may and it was based
on the availability of the venue if we
look at
the um availability of the venue at
other dates
and it's available in the evening then
the meeting can go ahead in the evening
so thank you thank you mr dawson thank
you chairman for indulging me on that
clarification
thank you okay thank you very much um
so i just want to be just want to be
clear what members
are voting on now so this this
uh recommendation here uh is the amended
recommendation am i correct yes
right okay uh in that case can we
chairman can i say something please yes
cancer edwards
um mention was made of a review but
there's no
mention in here of when a review would
take place
mr johnson could you help us out on that
yes thank you that the review will be
made when guidance changes
um we'll obviously have to review risk
assessments
as guidance changes and
look at the guidance and expectations as
as well
but until that guidance comes out from
government um
we can't really be any more specific
than that
other than saying we'll review as
guidance changes that's what i'm saying
it's not written on the
review is not mentioned as guidance
changes
oh yeah sorry an additional guidance
that emerges from risk assistance
yeah okay okay all right that's fine
okay
um tara could you now please take the
vote
uh yes chairman of course members as
before if you could just
indicate thought against rob stein
please want to call your name
they're starting with cather bassinger
please
four thank you very much councilman
four thank you councillor brianville
councillor bell against thank you
councillor boyce thought thank you
councilman
thank you durham i can see he's got his
agree sign up
thank you councillor edwards for
council mrs fleming or
key council fluker for
the councillor
thank you counselor keys
oh thank you that's lagging
four please tyrone why does counselor
durham think it's applicable to stick a
cartoon thing up when you can speak for
the rest of the meeting
i can't comment on that i'm sorry and
councillor mays thank you
uh four thank you very much councillor
morley
four thank you councillor morris
nuremberg code against thank you
councillor none four
mr shawnee four
oh it's done
silts
poor tara thank you very much councillor
swain
um i i better abstain i was distracted
uh for a couple of minutes
thank you very much account for mrs
thompson
four thank you and councillor miss white
paul please tara very much the chairman
the results of that are
twenty four four two against and one
abstention
thank you chairman okay thank you very
much
uh just in order that we that we do keep
uh
things on an even keel uh if we do take
a vote
could members make sure that they all
vote correctly please thank you very
much
uh i'm now going to move on to
agenda item number five
which is exclusion of the press and
public
so i move that under section 104
of the local government act 1972 the
public are excluded from the meeting
for the following item of business on
the grounds that it involves the likely
disclosure of
exempt information as defined in
paragraph
5 of part 1 of schedule 12a to the act
and that this satisfies the public
interest test if any member wishes to
second that motion
please unmute your microphone and state
your name
[Music]
got in there first thank you very much
cancer skeins
are we so can we agree by ascent
members
you've gone straight to the vote without
asking if anybody wishes to speak
this is for exclusion of the press or
public do you wish to
understand what the motion is i just
might
like to query it that's all yes go ahead
um uh chairman this is a very difficult
um
issue um uh and we need
to um be aware
that the public have a great interest
in this and there within the agenda item
there is no reason given why
we are going to discuss a course of
action
that is going to change our
decision uh that's been previously made
and having said that
um i think um also
where are we with the six-month rule on
um decisions of the council
well so that that is your question okay
so so this um this is actually
really just to receive uh
receive the uh some advice uh it's not
it's not a rerun of anything so i'm
satisfied that it can be heard
um yes sorry
uh i i'm sorry i've got a hand up i
can't see you it's counselor channel
well i think i've got to be careful what
i say but i'm
my understanding of the recommendation
is bit
is not quite that chairman i think
there's more to the recommendation
it's not just about receiving advice
right um
i i think that um at this stage
uh all we're seeking to do is to decide
whether we should go into closed
or not uh councillor boyce
has spoken or questioned it uh i'll go
now to councillor white
thank you mr chairman um my query um
from what council channel said
in that i don't believe that we are just
receiving advice
and i also when i read through the port
report i
read it that um i can't remember which
section it was in and i can't get it up
cause i only have the one screen that's
charged
is that it didn't it said that all the
rest of it should be or could be and i
think it should be debated in public and
it was only the advice of councel that
should be
held under pnc
so my concern is why are we deviating
from
normal council policy on why when it
should be in the public it is a public
matter
can we not discuss the meeting in public
but leave the council legal advice
under pnc which is where it should be i
honestly believe this meeting should be
split into two parts
because it's in the general interest of
the public and it affects them and i
think we are going against the council
constitution
i mean especially as it says in the
report
that it should be debated or could be
debated in public so what is
it uh is the constitution wrong or are
we wrong who's made the decision
to put some of it in all of it in pnc
when only
part of it has to be in p and c surely
things don't have to be in pnc they
should be
open for the public we've all got
nothing to hide but it's the question on
on the constitution really
uh mr crouch can you help us with this
please
yeah yes i think i can chairman um
contrary to what members have said it's
quite normal council practice actually
for legal
legal opinion which is based on the
contemplation of legal action
against us um and members have already
seen
what's in that report well i'm not going
to say too much about it because we're
still in public session
but um there is legal advice
that could determine whether legal
action
is taken now if if members debate this
um legal advice and my report
um and and plainly the receiving of the
advice will
affect whether members decide to re
to have the matter redetermined so i
don't think you can separate the
discussion on whether
the matter should be redetermined from
the legal advice because the legal
advice
is the only matter that you have before
you along with my report which is based
on the legal advice
so um if members decide to
to not resolve that matters be heard in
pnc then should members decide there
would be that the advice is not accepted
and there should be no redetermination
then that advice is available
and everything that members say is
available
to a party that might commence legal
action against us
yeah okay thank you very much uh
i've got um two speakers councillor
fluker councillor legend
uh i'll go to councillor fluker
first but i only want you to speak
councillor fluker on whether we should
or shouldn't go into private session
yeah thank you chairman and i i i'm
grateful
for what the monitoring officer says but
i mean i mean the
monitoring officer gave us completely
contradictory
evidence i think department advice uh in
relation to
uh two planning applications one at lan
land at wick hill which
members will remember and also
the geological survey at baraboo b
which i think members will remember they
were they were quite passionate
i'm sorry
i must ask you to decide whether we are
or are not going into private session
for this
that's what i want to speak to chairman
i think it's very important
that we understand what's happened in
the past and i was merely
reminding members of what happened over
land at wick hill
and the geological summit sorry i don't
think i don't think you're hearing me
i'm i'm i'm going to move on to council
chairman chairman the public gonna move
on to canada
the local government
thank you uh thank you chair um i i'm
grateful
um like councillor fluker very grateful
for the
information of the monitoring officer
and sharing his his legal advice
uh on this matter in my experience as a
member of the council
it's normal because of the potential
risks to the council to discuss such
matters that could have potential
implications in closed session
so i'm very happy to adopt the advice of
the legal officer
and to move into private and
confidential session to debate the whole
matter based on previous
experience and previous matters that
have been well advised
thank you chair thank you very much
no you cannot i'm going now to the go to
the vote
uh todd
thank you chairman excuse me chairman
recorded is that seconded
no chairman seconded seconded
please take the vote whether we should
go into private session or not
tara thank you
uh thank you chairman um members if you
could just indicate if you're fought
against or abstaining
for us to go into private session uh as
requested it is a recorded vote
and starting with the council of
passenger please
thank you councilman
thank you uh councillor bell
she's she's already gone tom okay sorry
apologies
uh council boyce against
thank you very much council mrs channel
oh sorry against you counselor
[Music]
chairman you totally ignored my raised
hand and i was see
merely seeking to offer my apologies for
having to use my sign because my audio
had failed so
you might have noted that i had to log
out and log back in so
lagging's information it's i was not
disrespecting you by uh not speaking
uh but i'm against this thank you okay
thank you
councillor edwards four thank you
uh council mrs fleming thank you
from the point of view of our league of
advice and i would have said that if the
chairman henry cut me off but the
restaurant
the public need to know this is
[Music]
abstain
maize 4
councillor morley
four councillor morris
ab stein
stamp for the cancer stilts
for the council swain
for cancer mrs thompson
council mrs thompson
and councillor miss white
thank you chairman the results of that
are 19
4 4 against and two abstentions thank
you
thank you very much so we'll now if you
could
uh tara if you could let me know when uh
we're in closed sessions
[Music]
of course chairman just bear with me a
moment we'll just get the stream stopped
thank you cancel the voice you've still
got your hand up